I want you to see something very
deep Isaiah
65:25 Christian preacher that was Isaiah
65:25 but also it's found in Isaiah 11
veres 1-10 Isaiah 11: 1-10 the wolf and
the lamb you put a wolf with the lamb
the wolf will tear up the lamb not in
that day they will feed together they'll
be friends the lion won't eat flesh will
eat straw like the ox and dust will be
the Serpent's food now you want me to go
deep on that statement about the serpent
the serpent will no longer bite and
poison and kill people by his venomous
bite but it also implies that the
serpent will never be
forgiven because here it's not simply
speaking of
serpents it's talking about the serpent
the devil whose judgment is
irreversible you caught it
even in the new heavens and the Earth
that serpent will continue to eat dust
because the Serpent's judgment is
irreversible though here it's on about
serpents in general that serpents will
no longer bite people or other animals
and kill them with their venom they're
just going to lick dust no more harming
people with their venom it has a deeper
message in that it shows the original
serpent who part of his judgment was to
be humiliated and brought to the dust of
the earth and lick
it that serpent his judgment is
irreversible yep Genesis 3:14 because
there's no forgiveness for him contrary
to what origin
said clear there is Genesis 314
Protestant quoted it so the lord god
Jehovah God said to the serpent because
you have done this cursed are you above
all livestock and wild animals you will
crawl on your belly and you'll eat dust
all the days of your life now some
people misread this passage let me
correct you want me to correct the
misinterpretation of this
passage crawling on your belly and
eating
dust doesn't prove that this is speaking
of literal
snakes in historical narrative please
pay attention I'm going to confuse you
you can have true history that actually
happens the way the Bible says it
happens but in the narrative you can
have figures described
symbolically what do I mean you can have
someone in an actual historical
narrative being described by an image
without this denying that this event
happened the way the Bible is reporting
it so the Bible will use symbols and
images to convey actual reality so I'm
not arguing for what Craig this heretic
is
arguing because people think the serpent
was an actual animal not according to
Revelation the serpent wasn't wasn't an
animal the serpent was a spirit creature
that was Serpentine in shape because the
serpent wasn't an animal possessed by
Satan the serpent is Satan Revelation
12:9 yep just like imra said Jesus looks
like a lamb in Revelation though he's
not literally a lamb but
he's literally a person Jesus who
appears as a
lamb okay Revelation 12:9 here it goes
the Great Dragon was hurled down the
ancient serpent called the devil so
notice Satan didn't possess a serpent
Satan is the serpent who leads the whole
world astray that's Allah of Muhammad
who was hurled to the Earth and his
angels with him Revelation
20:2 so the Satan appears as a serpent
Revelation
20:2 and he laid hold on the dragon the
old serpent which is the devil and Saye
does it say the old serpent possessed by
the devil no the old serpent who is the
devil and Satan and bound him a thousand
years so the serpent is Satan Satan
appearing and being symbolized as a
serpent so it's not even an animal so
then why does it say you'll crawl on
your belly and lick dust all the days of
your life let me show you what that
language means are you ready are you
ready for me to show you what that
language means Micah
7117 this is where we need to
know how the Bible uses such
language Micah
7:17 they shall lick the dust like a
serpent bam God is talking about
Israel's enemies he make them lick the
dust they shall all move out of their
holes like worms of the earth they shall
be afraid of Jehovah Our God and shall
fear because of thee what this means is
when you lick the dust that means you've
been defeated you've been vanquished
you've been hurled to the ground brought
under my
feet it's symbolic language of being
humiliated you who are high are brought
low to the Earth you get it let me show
you this metaphor again psalm 72:9
9-1 Psalm 72:
9-1 exactly Shel it doesn't mean it's an
actual serpent actually licking dust it
is biblical language saying the serpent
will be crushed he'll be humiliated
brought low under the feet of the
seed of the woman they that dwell in the
wilderness shall bow before you and his
enemy shall lick the dust there you go
the Messianic King when he comes to rule
over the world all the kings will lick
the dust under his feet because they'll
be forced to Bow and submit to him the
kings of tarish and of the Isle shall
bring presents the kings of Sheba and
siba shall offer gifts yes all the kings
shall fall down before him all nations
Shall Serve him did you catch it they
will lick dust who human
rulers why because licking the dust
means he has brought you low he's Hur
you to the ground he has subjected you
beneath his feet and humiliated
you so you see how badly we've been
misreading the serpent in Genesis
3 this is why Michael Heiser is right
when he's right he's right the serpent
is not an animal it is a spirit creature
who
Serpentine do you want me to continue
further on this to prove it to you
you want me and I did a session on this
go to my YouTube channel look for my
session on Satan and Lucifer but you
want me to remind you of it real quickly
invite more folks guys I want to see
over 300 bless my heart come on now for
the glory of Christ
okay the word for serpent in Genesis 3
is
Nash
Nash okay now let me blow you away in
numbers 214 to9
okay the word for serpent is
Nash in in numbers 21 veres
4-9 we're not going to quote it don't
quote
it Protestant note numbers 21: 4 to9 it
says when the people started murmuring
because there was no meat to eat God
sent to them fiery serpents pay
attention fiery serpents okay now why is
that amazing the word for serpents is
the plural for
but the word fiery get ready to to be
blown away if you don't remember you
need to pray for all nations and Israel
the nation is not God's chosen people
the chosen people of God is the Church
of Jesus Christ which is true Israel
United to Jesus who is the true Seed of
Abraham pray for Israel and all the
nations
equally get out you ready now the word
for fiery
serpents serpents is plural
of but the word fiery is
Sim Sim plural
singular do you know why that should
blow you
away the plural
sarim is what Isaiah saw the sarim of
Isaiah 6 verse
2-4 this is the same word refer refering
to those Spirit creatures standing
before God with six wings they are
seraphim the word s is not simply the
word for fiery it's the word for these
Spirit creatures
sfim showing you that the Nash the S are
actual Spirit creatures that God created
that guard the throne which is why
people believe that Satan was a cherub
because set is a throne Guardian which
is what a cherub is yep and it means
fiery one burning One Shining
one the same
word fiery
serpents I think that's the word order
order and the word for fiery is set set
what did Isaiah see in Isaiah 6 He Saw s
seraps with six wings and now let me
further connect Satan with these Spirit
creatures who are the throne Guardians
who are the cherubim because a cherub is
a throne Guardian so you can make a
strong case Satan was one of these
seraps who happened to be a cherub who
stood Before the Throne okay let me show
you you
ready Isaiah 4
1429 Isaiah 1429 there it's going to use
the word Nash Serpent and it's going to
use the word s Sara in the same verse
and it's speaking of a snake a Viper
Isaiah
14:29 Rejoice not thou whole Palestina
because the rod of him that smot thee is
broken now notice for out of the
Serpent's root shall come forth a
cockatrice and his fruit shall be a
firey
flying
serpent guess what the word for flying
fiery flying serpent is s so a serpent a
Viper a fiery flying serpent
Nash and S what's the point who told you
that was an actual animal in the garden
the Nash wasn't an animal but a spirit
creature that's Serpentine in shape who
is Satan himself that connects him with
the SIM these
fiery burnished glowing Spirit creatures
who stand Before the Throne as the
Guardians of the throne which means they
are cherubs yep Solomon that's where
they get it and you actually find
Solomon
ancient what they call
depictions rels or reliefs images of
Serpentine creatures Spirit creatures
that look like serpents in these
ancient cultures and civilizations you
find them in in Egyptian hieroglyphics
don't
you ancient depictions like Egyptian
hieroglyphics of creatures that look
like
serpents see that means when the Bible
is read in its ancient historical
context people would not have assumed
that the serpent is necess neily an
animal but but a spirit creature that's
Serpentine